Bảo, Nhi Kia Xeo có bay viết nhận định tại hội là tướng mấy bốn của Việt Nam thu hỗ sợ chủi đặc biệt tương dưới lộn nhé bản.
Bối bóng cáo của tổng vĩ thu tù lâm, chính bài mục tiêu tăng trường trường trí đe pê tối hiểu mười văn chăm.
Mỗi năm, trong dựa bản hành in khu, chăm mì sau hành in khu, chăm bà người.
Đưa truy đe pê, bình quân đồng người lên khoảng tảng nỉ, năm chăm đồng là Mỹ và năm hành in khu, chăm bà người.
Nhà bạn đã sẽ thao có đối lợi tại các hành chính, tình vọt bộ mái phát triển hạ tân, công nghệ cao và truy đu số, nhằm tăng cường bộ lợi khoảng lý vị và khách đủ cú giã.
Dưới học dành nhé bản nhận mạnh bài cho chính lượng và chính xí đối ngoại đồng lập của Việt Nam,
Bối các quân lị chính lúc thần diện, tham gia tích thực cả ASEAN và lý nước quốc, đồng thời khẩn định,
ngoại xa phân phá và trở linh dân dúc nân cao vị thì cú giã.
Chính xác phát triển lệ con người làm chung tân và đã mắn sình xa hội, ý tế và sống dục cũng đừng nhẹ bản quan tâm,
Nhưng một diện sáng trong chính lượng phát triển bình bự ứng của Việt Nam.